the drawing for the world record 1.6
billion dollar Mega Millions prize will
be held tonight the cash options soared
to nine hundred and four million dollars
the games website briefly shut down
yesterday as Mega Millions mania
intensified mark Strassmann is in
Tallapoosa Georgia near the Alabama
border where people are crossing the
state line to buy last-minute tickets
mark good morning good morning no place
in the state of Georgia sells more
lottery tickets than this convenience
store and a big reason is that it's five
miles from the Alabama border where
there is no Mega Millions and Alabamians
Drive in droves here for their piece of
the action
hoping to defy odds of one in 300
million to discover in an instant
tonight their filthy rich a million
dollars is life-changing but a billion
dollars is extraordinary John Crowe
hosts the Mega Millions drawing in
Atlanta its Mega Millions where tonight
he'll announce six random numbers worth
an historic fortune heads up for grabs
for almost anyone right now millions of
people across the US are thinking what
would I do if I won one point six
billion dollars what would you do well I
can't play wish me luck
but for people who can play donate to
charity and make a lot of people happy
going to mediate tsukushi move to an
island don't tell anyone the phone will
automatically start ringing financial
expert cosette white had a client who
won the lottery in 2012 earth wise learn
to say no because there will be people
always at you asking for a piece of the
lottery one winnings that you just came
into what also says winners should take
a lump sum instead of annual payments
the taxes may increase so you're going
to be paying higher taxes on a future
payment over the next twenty to thirty
years
Jackie and Gill Sisneros of Southern
California chose the lump sum when they
won a two hundred sixty six million
dollar jackpot in 2010 Jackie admits
their lifestyle changed but not
dramatically now I like to fly first
class instead of coach we still eat at
Outback I still like sizzler fried
shrimp
now they offer this advice to future
winners of tonight's Mega Millions it's
an over one
amount of money and you're gonna need
help he's smart about the decisions that
you make so that you don't make those
mistakes that are kind of cliche with
lottery winners this store sells so many
lottery tickets they've even set up long
tables for players to sit and make their
picks it could be a billionaires
winner's circle of course there are
players in 43 other states think of the
same thing people Gail just like you
yeah just like me is right because you
know i'ma buy a ticket Thank You mark
Strassmann I really do hope though that
a group wins that yeah I think it's more
fun when it's that much money and they
say listen if you win that much money
you should get a therapist you should
change your number and you should
certainly get a financial advisor you
know that phrase filthy rich never makes
sense to me because I don't think
there's anything filthy about being rich
and having a lot of a lot of people
dreaming today dream big people dream
big thank you Mark